welcome to film courage episode 150 it's
Super Bowl Sunday we thank you for
joining us on the day of Super Bowl 46
I'm Karen warden and I'm David Brandon
you can find our archives hello Karen um
you can find our archives on iTunes film
curse com la talk radio com and movie
garage well today's guests are director
Matt Adams and writer producer Andrew
Soltis they are the filmmaking team
behind a feature-length documentary
improv and everywhere that chronicles
how a group of New York comedian started
a cultural phenomenon Improv Everywhere
has been responsible for some of the
most original and creative public hoaxes
of the Internet age you probably know
some of their videos ranging from the
Grand Central Station freeze the best
buy hoax or the yearly no pants subway
ride just to name a few these are some
of the best videos on the internet
hilarious Improv Everywhere is a group
which causes scenes of chaos and joy in
public places traded in august two
thousand one by then actor comedian
Charlie Todd Improv Everywhere has
executed over 100 missions involving
thousands of undercover agents and these
stunts have grown Improv Everywhere to
have a huge fan base on providing them
close to a million YouTube subscribers
over 220 million video views a facebook
fan page with over 250,000 likes and a
Twitter following of over 26,000 on top
of the following Matt and Andrew helped
orchestrate a Kickstarter effort for the
documentary film Improv Everywhere that
raised over one hundred and twenty six
thousand dollars and that was just they
just reached their goal I think it was a
little less than a month ago it was a 40
day campaign over 1,600 backers and and
believe in the last day alone they
raised over nine thousand dollars please
welcome to film courage via telephone
Matt Adams and Andrew Soltis welcome
gentlemen hey thank you for having it on
hey thanks for being here we've we've
had so much fun doing research for the
show and I just have to put it out there
to the audience that if you're ever in a
bad mood if you're ever feeling down go
to youtube go to their site and look at
these videos and you will quickly be out
of a bad mood because there's just I
think my favorite is the is the
starbucks with you tell us more buses
are but it's just so funny like these
guys bring in or and a girl just to
total random stranger supposedly to the
audience view bring in these two desktop
computers they plug in the hard drive
and like one of them's Adele and the
girls like struggling with the monitor
and the best was this one guy that's so
incensed by the fact that they're not
like using laptops and he just like just
the looks on people's faces it's it's
priceless you got it you got to see that
anyway so many great thank you for
making us laugh over the years we really
appreciated yeah no thank you thank you
for both for joining us and lets you
know part part of understanding your
story guys his understanding Charlie
Todd so Matt do you remember the first
time you met Charlie Todd yeah I was
actually taking classes at The Upright
Citizens Brigade Theatre and I've seen
what he was doing and I reached out to
him and I said hey if you ever need me
help let me know I had recently
graduated from film school and I was
looking for stuff to do on a regular
basis and I like that what he was there
with Todd very cool well Andrew can you
tell us who is Charlie Todd Elliot is
you know sort of hard to figure out he's
not like most comedians you might meet
he's definitely the most serious
comedian and improviser I've ever met
and if anything he's very he's very
confident about what he likes in you
know prank or whether it's improv
everywhere for the website or whatever
it is he knows exactly what his taste is
and he's very good at achieving that um
definitely unique that he originally I
think came to New York to be an actor
right wasn't that his yep yeah I had a
he he studied and teaches are taught at
the epic Citizens Brigade Theatre in New
York and out of that sort of crude up
everywhere I originally was many more
people from the theater who were he in
missions which is what the group calls
the pranks but as it
throughout the years you know people for
mailing list became involved and you
know there's some missions that have you
know thousands of the people mouth
obviously it's grown much much much
bigger than just the Charlie and his
friends at the theater over the years
well I understand like the first prank
was was it at a bar or someone thought
he was ben folds or how did that first
transplant he convinced a group of
people that he was then fold it was like
he'd recently moved to the city and he
was just kind of excited about the fact
that nobody knew he was so I mean this
was back in my two thousand Q and like
smartphones can exist and like right now
you couldn't do that pract because
somebody would just take up their eyes
moon look up then fold do an image
search and be like now this is it you
you know and Matt you know for you it is
as I got to the point where Improv
Everywhere has gotten to be so big that
this is your full-time job yeah it is
something I do on a daily basis I mean
it has grown to the scope where I feel
so lucky to be able to do this colourful
time and when did that become the case
you know like like how many videos does
someone have to do how many people do
you have to reach you know to get to a
point where you know you're making a
living from from creating these great
little videos on YouTube well it's kind
of complicated because about 30 years
ago I actually left my day job to
completely focus on the filmmaking work
that I was doing and to also give Improv
Everywhere like one hundred percent
because we're at the time we're like the
video cameras were you know consumer
video cameras weren't good enough when
we compete with broadcast quality work
you know just just with having a mac pro
and like an hvx200 so you know I'd say
you know I left my job but four years
ago when I wasn't making a living doing
it for years ago I was working in
finance and actually had saved up the
money so i could give this camp and that
was my hope that was my Julian that
would I would actually have it were you
in a cubicle I wasn't in a difficult but
I was working in finance and it was
terrible but at the same time not that
lucky to have the job just because you
know i'll be a harsh economy they were
in and you know it also allowed me to
save up in
yet professional filmmaking a quick oh
no totally know there's their safety
within those cubicle you know barriers
but and I'm wondering too while you're
saving up during those three years are
you second-guessing it saying you know
what I like the paid vacation I like the
medical benefits and is this going to be
too scary to take this way now for me it
was never a question for me which is
always like how can I get out of this
day job and do this full time there
would never a question about like the
paid vacation or anything like that like
my sole goal has always been just to
make good work with you know with good
people people that I enjoy being around
sure sure and did you tell your
coworkers what your goal was or did you
kind of keep it on the DL and and then
well they've had found out about if
you're like a no pants subway ride I
think somebody you've seen my name
they're like you did this to like yeah
yeah yeah it's kind of funny in the
world of finance they're like oh well I
fell home and I make these videos where
people take their pants off on the train
right right in the daytime you're
praising Peter Lynch well I'm wondering
too did you did you when you gave that
two week notice if you did did you kind
of hear angels singing or were you I
mean did you feel like hey I'm on the
right path here when you gave that two
weeks notice you know I felt like I was
on the right path I was really excited
about it but at the same time I did ask
them if I could uh you know after six
months in there was any way that if
things weren't working out if I could
come back to the job oh my boss said of
course no problem at all but my boss's
boss's boss was like know if he's
leaving he's got a lead so that was kind
of more of like thrill from BTW i mean
obviously it's a little bit scary but at
the same time it made me give it rather
than under thinking about offense and
where do things stand six months out
well we were lucky enough to our mp3
experiment which is an annual plant that
we do was sponsored by yahoo where we
actually took the prank on tour so i was
able to do like when i left my job I
couldn't have actually done both so that
was the catalyst for leaving my job just
because we did have such tight deadlines
so I couldn't have done both so I just
you know I jumped right in and you know
worked as hard as I turn you know well
it's really that's gotta love hearing
that and clay Andrew what was your
introduction to improv everywhere and
and how did you sort of earn the respect
of Charlie and mad and and the whole
creative team there I it was it was
about a year ago a little more than a
year ago and it just started off with a
really simple project met needed help
reaching out to different people on
YouTube to try to find to to get the
original copies of the freezes that were
taking place all over the world so the
Grand Central further gradual an
immunity on YouTube and it's where you
know hundreds of people freeze in place
at a given time and that's a really
caught on for the most widely no
missions that in pelennor has ever done
and so we were trying to collect videos
from on the world people who did that
for the doc and Matt and I worked on
that is very part time very slow no I
wasn't getting paid it was just because
I loved in front of everyone and I had
seen the videos on YouTube and out of
that we started working together a
little bit more because we really got
along and it just sort of grew and grew
from there when we will finding things
in your in sync with and we just sort of
became a good game and yang and
partnered up well and as we're working
on the dark charlie because there's not
a whole ton of people involved in the
core group of improv everywhere I
started helping out with a few of the
actual missions and I actually edited
some of the remastered videos like the
best buy video that came out which was a
ok nothin I think I'll five and I recut
the whole thing and remastered it and so
I've been helping out with a few nice
things but it really was just sort of a
you know a creative connection and it
just sort of grew out of that and then
saw out how long have you guys been
friends for then is this is this a more
recent friendship or how long do you
guys go back I did a little over a year
I mean yeah like Anderson had no reason
on like we just became fast friends and
we just heard of working together
like I think that's like a key to like
obviously the character making you know
work that you believe in its just having
people around you that are totally
positive and supportive of each other
yeah cuz I was just thinking that I mean
you know I you guys have probably had a
lot of people a lot of people that have
tried to get involved with your success
you know they see the videos they laugh
they crack up and they try to somehow
gain access to you guys gain gain access
to the inner circle what is it about
Andrew where you sort of allow them in
and and and so what stood out about
Andrew well it's kind of like any
relationship where it's like you feel
that you are doing something that you
believe in and they are also adding
things that help fulfill your vision so
sometimes I'll see something and you
know I will be like the best that I can
with it and then i'll talk to andrew
about it and then he'll have something
new to it something that work that i did
you see and buy first okay all right now
forgive me I was sighs I caught me mid
sip there so just just drinkin else is a
good old you know kirkland signature
getting water it's not here folks Super
Bowl Sunday the drink of line um you
know couple coming background because
here's what I get fascinated about is um
is Charlie Todd and these videos they've
been seen millions of times over you
know 220 million views and and he's an
actor he's right there in New York and I
just can't help but wonder how many
times is he offered various TV roles
film roles is that happening well
Charlie has offered you know he has been
offered you know jobs in the past but if
he never been like a priority for him of
course when he moved to New York it was
slightly different but you know he
really his problem with acting was a lot
of the problems that I think I had a lot
of what creative people have this bit
they feel so little control with other
people's work so improv every world was
a way for him to be creative and for him
to use his own voice rather than having
to just read somebody else's long right
and then to sort of wait by the phone or
whatever for someone to choose and why
you know he was really proactive about
that like you know I didn't one of the
interviews that I had with him he just
said you know I decided at a bar one
night no I'm gonna do my own thing
everything I have and I'll just see how
it goes yeah and then what he's doing a
TED talks and then he's also has a book
doesn't he was another gem yeah yes a
book yeah he has a book with another
senior agent Alex chord Alice and they
wrote yeah called anything cause
anything ok you know and coming back to
to sort of just the people that that
that have game gained acclaim and
attention on the internet you know what
why do you guys think that we don't see
as much integration of internet
celebrities and mainstream television
you know is it still sort of like this
little brother syndrome when are we
going to see more integration more
crossover between these worlds I like
that well you know I think you know the
world have collided very quickly and
it's one of those things where you know
we did have a television pilot in 2007
and 2007 a lot of network executives
we're looking youtube like oh my gosh
this is the best new thing or this is
that this is the brand new thing and you
know they had reached out to improv
everywhere and i think the network also
reached out to another youtube channel
for awesome beretta and you know both of
us had pilots and neither of em were
picked up okay there's also something
you know very different between the type
of youtube video that is like a one-hit
wonder and those people who are creating
consistently good content like improv
everywhere so i think after you sort out
all the sort of you know one time hits
it's harder to find that many things
that could really be adapted for a
longer format sure yeah you know that's
that's a great point because you know
what works it is two or three minutes
maybe like the perfect length to just
you know put a link in the email and
click send to your front mm-hmm do
either of you like being in front of the
camera and featured in any of these
stunts I'd say you know I don't mind it
but like you know because I come from a
little bit of a background in acting so
before when I was younger I was a little
bit more all over the place like I was a
musician I you know I was interested in
acting and stand-up comedy but when I
really started when I got my first video
camera was just like I did enjoy being
behind the cameras so much more just
because I just I love working with
people and I just love them working
people with people through certain
processes and andrew and i fully behind
the camera guys okay that's yeah I not I
have accidentally been I think I did it
a couple of clips of a couple of in
private or videos purely by accident
okay so Matt all these years you've
never appeared in any of the Improv
Everywhere videos I've been in them in
random spots like it's always fun to be
able to even in the trailer like there's
a part where I have my camera out and
I'm in it but I'm just like in the
background and earlier you mentioned the
mobile desktop prank and the one guy
that was just saying oh my gosh I can't
believe that these people have these
giant computers I was the one that
actually interviewed him sometimes I
play the role of the film's beauty but
just happen to have a video camera on it
so sometimes I voices in them but I'm
not actually in front of the camera and
how are you able to play this straight i
justjust you don't I mean how are you
able to do that it's how's the camera
not shaking the entire time from you
laughing well you know i just took to it
because I know what it's like to get
shaky footage and you know over the
years you know we have so many different
cameraman so it's just a goal that I
have to just play it as absolutely
straight as I can and actually to talk
as little as i can to leave other people
the opportunity to you know for them to
try to figure out exactly what it is
because when i first started i would
talk a little bit too much and then I
realized oh my gosh I'm cutting off
their grade line so I stopped and it was
just I would only say things to to get
them to start talking more that's great
the other thing is it is sort of an
improv very sort of a misnomer because
these missions are very highly
choreographed and planned and usually
when were what we're doing one of the
shooting one of them we've been able to
rehearse it and you know it's got it we
can do it several times or what
it is to make sure we get it exactly the
way we want it so you know usually were
highly planned beforehand and we're not
you know too broken up by what's
happening yeah they're definitely like
really planned out but there are things
that we can just never anticipate like
that one guy at the starbucks or just a
random video cited needing to oculus
right I think there was a guy on the
subway to write that thought that it was
real and you guys all had a break
character didn't you think that there
was a real fight and he got upset yes
that was for our Jar Jar subway car last
year at rush yet I was just like oh my
god this is a real life he didn't even
believe us after we told everything but
then we had to like actually have the
actors look up smile he realized it was
big and then he kind of laughed if he
was like oh my god other than that we
are on the line with Matt Adams and
Andrew Soltis part of the creative team
behind improv everywhere and the
upcoming Improv Everywhere documentary
film and you know you guys have been
talking about that you plan these stunts
intricately and you take you take some
time out can you talk a little bit more
about how much time do you really put in
and help and maybe a little bit more
about the rehearsal process well I mean
it varies from Frank like if you take
something like her no pants subway ride
it's more of just trying to figure out
the train lines trying to figure out who
is going to run a train line because as
it's gotten so big we have to have a
series of what we call general people to
take on the responsibility for people
know exactly what to do but then if you
take another prank like we've done
called the say something nice prank well
we had a podium built and we had a
megaphone attached to it and we just
have lacquer that said say something
nice more work goes into the actual
construction of like I just props you
know which even though we do you know
internet videos we still do have liked
rock and then how many stunts have you
done and then once you review the
footage you say you know what I'm not
really feeling this does that ever
happen
no that's actually it's never happened
there has been a couple pranks that
we've tried to do that we want to do
again but there's never been one that's
what oh I don't like this idea because
you know we always are sure of ourselves
in terms of the idea like we fall in
love with the idea when it you know when
it comes to us or Charlie or somebody
that has pitched it to us through the
internet so we're usually pretty
comfortable with what we're actually
doing so that never actually happened
and were there any pranks that were
unsuccessful in terms of the audience
reaction um you know I think that our
April Fools pranks sometimes get a lot
of criticism because you know we can we
do a print every April first you know an
April Fool's prank to sort of it for our
Internet audience so one year we did one
called the best funeral ever it was
based off of our best game ever prank
where we turned a little deeply skin
into a professional major league game we
had when we had people announcing the
game hot dog vendors all the players had
like baseball cards programs that were
being handed out so we thought you know
it's a do a prank where we have a family
with you know the person that died
didn't have a lot of surviving relatives
we can show up and give them the best
funeral that they've ever obviously
they're always general is but give them
an amazing funeral and people look at
that like it was real and they'll just
how dare you do this is so disrespectful
but being kind of thing was fake I mean
the family was everybody was composed of
actors my parents were actually an older
couple in it to give it a little bit
more legitimacy um Amy know we had a
fake cough and you think the people
would know that it was fake because we
had a Dracula I mean if you looked
a little closer did you see that there
was a Dracula cough we have somebody
play the fries and everything um yeah so
definitely sometimes people do is see
these eggs in a way that said how could
you scoop that we would actually do this
and I understand a few the pranks have
gotten you or or maybe Charlie into some
hot water like the you too
hoax I think he was what on the top of
his apartment complex roof and the cops
came yeah yeah that was that was really
interesting because I think there was a
part of Charlie that wanted to get
arrested because when it came down to it
you know in fact you to performance
happened so I was watching some of the
footage and there was a moment where
Charlie looked at somebody and he says
you know if the cops do come and arrest
us that that would be perfect because
that's exactly what happened and when it
came down to it when you really can't
get into trouble playing your guitar
work right and then Andrew tell us what
happened with the best buy hoax like I
guess security was called or the police
were called yeah the police were called
by best buy and they showed up and
essentially we're told told the store
employee that it's not illegal to wear
you shirt and khaki pants so it made for
a video it was a great punch line but
they on best buy was not to is because
you know and we do some of these where
the prank takes place in a store and it
is sort of interesting you know is that
really a problem is the public spaces
summon my question but in this case
although it really happens they thought
it was appropriate to call the cops and
and when the cops got there they didn't
know what to say but I'm going
interesting it was interesting moment
for sure yeah you know and and behind
the scenes I mean how much pressure do
you guys feel to sort of top the last
video or continue to improve and get
better and reach more and more people I
mean did you guys a lot of pressure on
yourselves personally I don't you know
because i think if you use the more
pressure you feel the worse it's going
to come out so I just try to give every
prank hundred percent just because when
you're constantly feeling pressure
you're thinking about that pressure not
what you should actually be doing in
Andrew as a relative newcomer to the
team you know what what have you
observed for from these guys in terms of
how they go about strategize
preparing and executing these videos one
thing that's that's always really struck
me is how meticulous everything is it
seems you know for every bit that a fuse
whimsical and fun in the videos online
there's that much planning and thought
that goes into it you know there's
there's it's in some ways like a film
shoot although it's not you know not
nearly as complex but you know there
there's medieval wouldn't call sheets
and there's be equivalent oh you know
releasing things when it's going to be
the best for the YouTube audience and
the other the whole you know the whole
study you could do about the best way to
release these videos online the best way
to reach your audience and all that kind
of stuff so I've always been amazed how
this is sort of like a little mini
studio model where there are a lot of
things that mirror what you're doing at
least a feature film but with these
short little videos video internet you
know and man I mean you kind of already
hinted at it that you do receive ideas
but it makes me wonder how many ideas
are ourselves generated amongst your
crew and and how often do you have folks
submitting ideas and how often will you
actually take one of those ideas and go
out and create the stunts well I think
Charlie gets submissions on a daily
basis you know especially when somebody
found out find out he's being from
everywhere guy the first thing they want
to do is be like oh my gosh you guys
should do this project are you guys to
do that but you know as we were talking
about best buy rock prank was actually
submitted by a high school student in
taxes i believe and Charlie got the
email and when charlie gets an email of
an idea that he likes his eyes light up
and some email be kid back immediately
because the kid said what you guys
should do is you can get all your agents
blue polo shirts khaki pants go into a
Best Buy you just stand around or do it
with red shirts and khaki pants and go
to a target Oh Sheldon vacuum is like
thank you thank you random stranger on
the internet we're doing this next week
and and does and does and because you
can't help but wonder like you know
because you said you know you've kind of
made this transition we're in private
where it becomes your full-time job and
you start hearing of the
big companies that are involved in these
videos whether it be starbucks best buy
i mean there you sort of mentioned
target i mean is the money coming solely
from YouTube Partner Program or are you
getting sponsorship money from these
companies we definitely not get exposure
from starbucks their target or best
buy they would like us not just really
what we're doing you know they are you
know super happy about it you know
especially when we go into their store
and it's all they want like like they
should is for their business to run
smoothly um but you know we do get some
some money through like sponsorships
we're will view a video and somebody
will say hey we'd like to sponsor one of
your videos you don't have to mention
our name in the video but if you could
put a card at the end saying like
brought to you by kind of like the PBS
model so that is something that has
happened more and more and it still
hasn't happened to time but those videos
do help out in terms of life hoping to
pay the bill sure and those are mostly
for videos that we couldn't do otherwise
like for example the musicals where
requires a tremendous amount of plan our
cameras like you know hidden cameras and
you know construction to set everything
up and things that you know have a
really high budget that we couldn't put
together just on our own mm-hmm and
andrew has the online space gotten more
competitive I mean are there other
improv groups out there trying to outdo
you guys um there are definitely other
groups that are trying to imitate i
don't know i don't i don't think there's
any competitor that releases on a
schedule i can probably wear mostly what
what I've noticed is the trend with
advertisers to copy this or a flash mob
because it's very buzzy it's very trendy
and you know Microsoft and a number of
big companies have taken this sort of
type of short video can they they could
play a very viable model marketable
thing and they go out and they do their
own flash mob this is a it's not a term
that it would probably but then go out
and you know to pay a hundred actors to
dance in Times Square or something like
that and there there have been that is
actually wasn't had that you were you
mentioned
the other dead the added grandcentral
delivered with that yeah yeah there was
an ad at Grand Central where because one
of our most famous videos is frozen
grand central over 200 people freeze in
place at Grand Central Station to the
specified time everybody moves is
nothing it happens now there was
recently a commercial where a guy shows
up in something that really it seems
like Grand Central Station and you've
got like a raincoat trench coat on and
at a at a time he looks at his watch he
pairs office is coat and starts dancing
and then you need Ely disattached it
says the flashmob location has been
changed to such and such so it is cool
though in a way to see you know our work
being well just sort of like
infiltrating the mainstream you know
what people are seeing on a daily basis
to see that somebody actually knows what
it is that's terrific you know and you
guys had mentioned a little bit about
this sort of the largest production
budget that you've had for any of these
stunts was the biggest scale thing you
guys have done I don't really know what
the largest one we have you know even
like something that like the no-pants
subway ride you know those are like we
don't really put a dime into it you know
we have all of our own equipment so our
model is pretty much not to sense
anything unless we absolutely need it
and like Andrew said like some of those
are the bigger pranks like the you know
the music because those costs a lot more
you have to hire somebody that looks
like a Santa Claus you have to get
location releases from like a mall you
have to have all those hidden cameras
installed you have a control room so you
know we choose those pranks to do with
advertisers because the ones that we do
we really try not to put any money into
it because we aren't making a ton of
money out of it you know we you know we
we make very little from it so we try to
do you know only have the big pranks
with with brand are always shocked by
the amount of companies that donate
their services whether a week we've
encountered this the major way with the
film but even with the regular video
releases no just there's just a lot of
excitement about making these videos
come together so a lot of people donate
their time their equipment their
services etc
just to see it just to see it happen and
Andrew which has been your favorite hoax
and why oh man I think I have to say
that's why I just because I spend so
much time in it and I actually got to
see the law tapes of you know my day on
so you know when he said although it
would not make for a good YouTube videos
through our rotate from this yeah it's
really fascinating to watch this thing
happen over the course of the amount of
time it took on the tape was a really
cool experience to see that so I have to
say that's not what about for you Matt
um it's really hard for me to say
because they're all special in different
reasons for different reasons but if I
had to pick I would say either high five
escalator King Philip's of 4 i'll go
into kate felt before just because it
was fun the way we documented it we went
to the museum and we have somebody that
had looked like he just looked like tin
filled before he was standing in front
of a painting and you know he said he
looked at his mom was like oh my gosh
you seeing this I looked exactly like
this guy so he had a costume build it
custom-made and we went to the museum
and basically he stood in front of it
and was offering to sign autographs
Charlie worked as kind of like his his
little piggy manager and was saying you
know we do have principal the fourth if
you'd like it autograph we'd be more
than happy to provide that for you and
they fill up the fourth which is kind of
quiet and you know he was signing
autographs and what was so fun about it
for me was because it took a traditional
you know experience in a museum and just
made it more lively so people were
coming up and getting autographs and now
with today's technology we have
everybody shooting but using DSLR and I
had like um you know I had everybody
lost but I had like a little sound mixer
stuff down my pants so if the end of the
day like we dictate kicked out but no
even you are making a video because
filming in the museum is not legal it's
kind of like a thrill of like being able
to pull it off it was kind of like a
combination of lightning the idea and
also liking the weight and we're able to
pull it off because we would have been
able to do something
not ten years ago because videos hair
for something bigger well you know too
it's funny because i think you know New
Yorkers get a bad rap but they have such
a great sense of humor and a great heart
to them do you think that a lot of these
pranks have been successful because
they've been in New York and people kind
of they seem to bond together especially
post 9-11 at least in my California eyes
that's what it seems like but I could be
wrong here well I think it goes both
ways just because we did this one prank
called look up more where we had about
75 people dressed in black standing in a
series of windows and at a specified
time Charlie would put his hand he was
watching everybody from the windows on
the street level and it was four levels
so he would put his hand on the trash
can and it would let them do something
and then he would take it off the trash
can and that was to go on to the next
step now when you see 75 people in
windows dressed in black especially
fairly close to being right after 911 it
can create three concerns mmm which was
totally make sense um you know security
guards would come out and be like what
are you guys doing because you know they
are trained to you know for performance
art you know they're just trying to do
their job and to have things run
smoothly of course that's we would never
do anything like that energy to to take
over his door or do anything malicious
but you know it is a concern so you know
I think it goes both ways like I think
you know for a frank like high-five
escalator we have you know one of our
agents to rob leatham giving thousands
of high fives at the top of an escalator
that's something different words like it
definitely left threatening but
something where you see some bleep are
people dressed in black I mean you have
to be a little bit scary yeah or if you
see 80 people dressed as Best Buy
employees it I can't help but wonder
have you ever had any sort of because
you know sometimes these stunts you're
involving hundreds of people thousands
of people have you had any renegades who
sort of try to somehow sabotage one of
these one of these skids soror stunts
you know like they give themselves on
the inside and then they try to just do
something just totally just totally
stupid or something we haven't I think
that's one of the reasons that we
haven't is just because you know it's
small
all group of people I mean when it comes
down to it there's really only a few of
us involved with you know making the
video so we really it's such a tight
lipped group of people so it's it's
never actually happened where the word
has got out if somebody assured up so
many times I try to run it in Andrew now
you have some additional big names
behind the film right including parks
and recreations Aubrey Plaza musician
Ben Folds and comedian Nick Kroll how
did they come on board yeah that's
actually a probably better question for
that because he spent so long prepping
all interviews and doing on the energies
I wasn't really on board until after all
that I've been completed so not know him
so yeah yeah sure um well already you've
mentioned earlier the girl with the you
know the giant computer on her lap that
was actually Aubrey Plaza in that
private okay oh yeah I was awesome um
you know it like I said you know such
small things that you know sometimes
will be something with 200 people and
sometimes we'll do something with like
three or four and you know I think
there's more of a concern for this for
the prank idea getting released when
there's a large group of people but
something like King felt before you know
I didn't mention a museum Pater's the
Museum of the metropolitan museum of art
which is like one or two people it's
harder for that to get out and get
leaked for somebody to ruin but back
your question about you know the
celebrities Nick Kroll was one of the
people that was dancing in the windows
look up more so you know they had
participated in some of our pranks and
you know over the course of the
documentary being made they became
famous or were starting to become famous
and you know when we were able to when
we started cutting it together it was
just nice to have a celebrity is
attached so Matt whose idea was it to
make the documentary um well I
approached Charlie about it I'd say a
little over three years ago and I was
still working at the bank and that was
something that I said you know I think
we should have a documentary sir didn't
really have these videos that are being
seen millions of people but the wildest
video is probably like to maybe six or
seven minutes so for me it was something
I really was passionate about in terms
of creating a feature-length documentary
and all through the learning experience
for me I've ever made a feature like
documentary before and instead of going
back to school to get my masters I
thought to myself you know what I think
would dispute with people that I know I
can make this happen it'll be an
incredible learning experience for any
without having to drop you know hundred
thousand dollars by getting my mattress
and and and so you know there you have
the idea when did you start because
obviously I mean three years ago I mean
did you start filming the documentary
three years ago or is okay so it's been
ongoing for three for three years and
then when did you start thinking okay
you know what maybe we should turn the
Kickstarter to help us um you know
finish this movie I'd say gender what do
you think about like six months ago
practice month ago yeah I mean we had
sort of had it in the back room I
needn't necessarily think Kickstarter
until our six months ago we knew were
going to need to do some fundraising and
I think initially I thought was private
investors got a typical film out but
yeah then we then we after much
discussion decide to go Kickstarter you
say much discussion I mean was it a
struggle deciding you know whether to
launch a campaign and in India in the
end why did you do it yeah I mean
absolutely i think in the end it came
down to we thought it was right for the
audience that would would be watching
the film and we thought you know in
front of yours is so driven by the
internet that we would already have an
existing base people we can draw on task
for both the film and also because we we
thought would be a great way to build
fast now i'm just going to what a few
private investors you know Kickstarter's
great way to start spreading the word so
you know there are some people we still
want to interview there's some footage
we still need to get we had a lot of
work left to do on the film so we
thought it'd be a great way to generate
buzz which it bit we got you know 100
emails from different people throughout
the course the campaign whether it was
just you have my support or some people
offering to composer to sell more you
know provide post services like that
people who have
you know access to video equipment that
said you know if you want to help you
shoot the rest of it or whatever it is
so then I did definitely much further
than just the monetary aspect of the
campaign in the whole a whole nother
thing happening there yeah and another
thing is like in terms of like the buzz
that it's created like if we had a
couple private investors we wouldn't be
doing this interview right now so I mean
like look even like just something like
this is so cool that like people are
seeing what we're doing and want to talk
to us about it because we're excited
about it but it was just a couple people
involved with providing the funds we
wouldn't be doing that no very cool well
thank you i appreciate i remember David
when you you showed me the the
Kickstarter video and ya know you know
yeah we know we can but you know but
we've we've been familiar with these
videos for a while oh yeah you know I
think you know we've been telling people
in preparation for this inner we've been
telling people about the freezing and
grand central station and sort of pants
off in the New York subway you know then
all of a sudden you know because we
mentioned best buy and maybe they
haven't seen that or heard of that and
we mentioned a couple other things but
then we mention those two and then all
of a sudden the light bulb goes off I'm
wondering to Matt like what kind of
chaos are you experiencing behind the
scenes you're raising over a hundred K
you have 1600 backers I mean people
probably think it just seems so easy but
I'm sure it was a lot of like a
rollercoaster ride wasn't it yes it
completely was and andrew was the
campaign manager and he and I think
you'd be better for this question yes he
was amazing in terms of like really
making sure that everything was
accounted for it was a full-time job for
us for 40 days I mean we would work on
this thing like 15 to 17 hours it did
definitely a full-time job and the
hardest i would say the hardest thing
about it is just keeping the momentum
going I mean it's really a lot of it
comes down to just you know marketing
yourself in your film like that said 17
hours a day for 40 days and you know you
can get half way and you get to get that
40 or 50 thousand dollar mark you can't
then you can take it only a half a
second to take a breath and appreciate
that you've got enough fine you know
it's so hard because this is all
happening you're you're like shocked and
touched
all these people are donating to the
filaments incredible it's hard to talk
to see $50,000 we say okay one another
50,000 or of this is going to happen if
you know it's tough not to just say well
it's incredible I you have to keep going
back every day medicines you know I
probably said the thousand emails over
the course the campaign just about the
campaign you know whether it's to
journalists or you know blogs things
like that just to spread the word and
you know hope that people will not only
donate money but donate space on their
website to refer traffic from the web to
the K star things like that and Andrew
when did it reach sort of the height of
a frenzy was it the last day of the
campaign well it's always the first in
the last days that are the biggest just
as a result of the way you know the
excitement goes in the beginning it was
just seeing if they want to give it that
initial boost and in the end everyone
wants to see it happen I should also
mention that at the end there are a
handful of people who say oh no this is
actually happening I gotta get my flesh
out but more than that you know probably
40 times that was that number of people
are the number of people that increase
their pledge you know we send out a
message I last day and said hey we've
come this far we're so thankful for you
didn't if everyone could have bumped a
pledge up a couple of bucks it would
really help put us over the top and
hundreds of people did that del Este so
it's just really incredible yeah benefit
as I'm saying the first and last day the
middle was the most difficult around the
holidays we were at a standstill right
now there was one day I think your age
you know five or six hundred bucks ball
all day when you see that and you
capture that the numbers we needed to be
raising over 3,000 a day so it's real
tough to have those days it's sort of
discouraging but you've got to just get
back up and exporting and keep keep
going going going we're doing a lot of
prep work during that time to get ready
for after the holidays so we can really
hit strong as soon as it all and started
using their computers again hmm yeah we
had those days ourselves with a couple
campaigns were with where you just think
it's not going to happen
it's that lull in the middle besides the
the time commitment that you talked
about the 15 to 17 hours a day what are
some other misconceptions people have
about crowdfunding I mean you guys make
it look so easy as so many other
campaigns do I think people I as you
mentioned earlier in the broadcast I
wrote an article with Matt for the
website to some courage website on one
of the things I mentioned in there is
you know I think there's still the
conception that Kickstarter is a tool to
reach out to friends and family for
donations for your project but the
biggest thing that we were focused on is
getting that random person in some
random country that we've never talked
to before to get interested and donate
to the film and that's the biggest thing
I learned for sure is that it's a game
of getting the word out beyond your
media networks you know if you can't
deep enough and go far enough and enough
circles you'll start hitting people that
are new that have never heard of improv
everywhere so while we got a lot of
support from you know people who see the
videos and no nothing like that we got
more support from people who had never
heard of it or never been apart of it
before which is which was really great
for us we're really happy about that
yeah that was amazing to feel that level
of support from people that we've never
met or maybe we'll never be yeah it was
cool too because in your article you
have a hyperlink to a gawker com article
entitled end online panel and handling
forever and it's a it's a pretty wow I
mean it's a in your face article but
it's actually really good about what
some people perceive as crowd flying and
they they liken it to getting that icky
feeling at a party when your friend
talks about amway you know or tries to
sell you on some multi-level marketing
things so I it's interesting how you you
tied that in because I think it is very
true I'm people are getting turned off
and finding that way to do it as
successful as you can it's great and you
mentioned eight different things and I
thought it was great you said um prepare
press contacts identify your network
choose your niche targets you know
incentives
and be human be visual thought that were
those are all great points we're running
out of time here guys I'm so sorry but
we're getting the signal to wrap up we
want to thank you both when do we
envision the film will be all finished
we are looking for release in 2013 early
in 2013 we hope that's fantastic and is
that going to be on The Improv
Everywhere site or will you have your
own site for that will probably have umm
it'll probably be on both but we're
going to we're not sure exactly how
we're going to distribute it yet but
those details will be on if you can
follow on Twitter or you know all the
updates will probably be on The Improv
Everywhere say there's a little film to
have to keep you updated with where
we're at not very cool and I should also
mention there's a there's a new mission
coming up tomorrow so check out a
prevalent wacom or YouTube channel
improv everywhere oh very cool so it's a
pretty the videos already done and it's
being uploaded tomorrow yes it's what up
tomorrow no can't wait ok after
Superbowl oh yeah you know for more on
the film please visit Kickstarter and
search Improv Everywhere also check out
Improv Everywhere com on Twitter improv
every film they have and also improv
every for the just for the movement
itself facebook.com slash Improv
Everywhere and of course you know head
over to youtube and just go through the
whole collection at improv everywhere
again thank you gentlemen and look
forward to seeing tomorrow's a prank
very very excited yeah yeah and the best
thing I the best thing I could say to
you guys is we had a lot of fun just
just doing the research on this and
diving into all the videos and I think
part of what we want to do today is we
want to head back and maybe continue the
research even after the interview and
just continue to explore what you guys
have done so we can't be a more thrilled
to have you join us on the program today
yeah thank you both appreciate it well
thank you oh yeah very welcome and thank
you Ronan out there and and for all that
you do for us yeah Ronan odds are told
chief engineer here at la talk radio
Thank You Ronan and would you like to
hear your project or business mention
during one of our shows are displayed on
our site to advertise with film courage
calm and our radio program please
inquire through film courage
come via our contact page and next
Sunday coming up as mentioned filmmaker
Meg pinsonneault an award-winning
filmmaker festival screen director and
screenwriter in Los Angeles she is the
founder of the production company
thirsty girl films which is the semi
exclusive content provider for the
auteur filmmaking website movie garage
and meg is currently working on a
featured doc entitled guapa beautiful a
visually compelling story about a
filipino families remarkable journey to
help their three kids with facial
deformities for more on Meg please visit
thirsty girl films com at thirsty girl
film on Twitter and feast of the foolish
calm a short film with a shot in Joshua
Tree California and until next Sunday
have a great week
you